السودان التي عرفت يوما بسله غذاء العالم
شعبها مهدد بالجوع اليوم الاشتباكات
الدائره منذ ايام في البلاد شلت الحركه في
ارجائها واغلقت الكثير من المحال التجاريه
صرخات السودانيين على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي على قائله ان لم يقتلنا الرصاص
فسيقتلنا الجوع او العطش برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي التابع للامم المتحده اعلن تعليق
جميع عملياته بعد مقتله ثلاثه من موظفين
وبالتالي فان نقل العاملين او مواد
الاغاثه لم يعد ممكنا في الوقت الراهن
السودان اعتبرت في اوائل التسعينيات سله
غذاء العالم نظرا لما تملكه من مساحات
زراعيه لكن ما توالى عليها مؤخرا من احداث
وصراعات رفع عدد السودانيين المهددين بخطر
جوع الى 15 مليونا ولا ندري كم ستكون
اعداد متضررين من الاشتباكات اليوم